foreign
one of the most controversial things
that are uncensored and and highly
requested are gen stories bro and this
this a lot of people don't even know
what genre right because a lot of them
are like you know do we believe in it do
we not it's just in the Quran so we just
blindly submit there's no Blind Faith
all right so these things are real
anyone that is watching this and has had
encounters with Jin they know what we're
talking about is not just Hocus Pocus
stuff no but to a lot of people they
might not know what genar so you want to
give a quick like five minute summary
bro no all right
so
Jin is from the realm of what we see the
Unseen we say the Unseen live
and this is um
very popular topic where people discuss
it it's um
I think it's sometimes taken to an
extreme or the other
and that's why a lot of people might get
too scared about it or get kind of
dismissive and be like well you know
it's just uh
next stories and just Fork right which
is not
and it is a popular topic we say in
Arabic a gin Will Gins gin and sex the
two most popular topics that people it's
like a very related words but yeah Jin
even the root word it comes from
something that is not seen like for
example
right Jannah is uh Paradise which is
also from the live and um it is a spirit
that was created by Allah okay from
smokeless fire
as Allah does the Quran and it is
basically what the devil is
let's keep it as simple as possible
iblies the main yeah he's a jet but
Christians believe he's an angel Fallen
Angel
okay Muslims do not believe that Angels
Fall because the way they were created
implying that like an angel of a fallen
angel implies that God has somehow
created an imperfect uh worshiper that
he's specifically related to worship of
course this is an issue of theology it's
not necessarily like a proof of it's
just this is what we believe rise not to
uh but Allah the Angels without fault in
terms of worship
they do what he says and as opposed to
humans
and as opposed to Jin so Angela created
from light humans were created from uh
mixed mud from different colors as
Hadith says right like we're talking
about like black red why all kinds of
different mud
and the general create from smokeless
fire and so different substances
and three different Creations they all
the two share one same characteristic
the Gen and human beings which is the
ability to choose
and the angels do not right
like they just said we praise be to you
we
don't know anything except what you
taught us the Angels responded
and uh however the Jinn and Adam they
have the freedom of choice or beniath so
this is kind of like a just a main
definition and distinction between the
three Creations what's gin it's a people
say ghost different
countries different
um
ethnicities different nationalities will
have different variations or you know
with regards to but it's part of one
thing is in common that pretty much all
have the concept of a an unseen being
unexplained and so on I would say that
the Muslim and the Christian
judeo-christian tradition who have the
closest definitions or the closest
similarities then you have
you know all the way from the Amazon to
Africa different concepts Native
Americans right spirits and so on
spirits of the forest spirits of animals
and so on and so forth all these will
have different definitions and
understanding and it's important to know
what a gin is because
of who shaytan is again right who
iblises that's why so you can know
exactly who your enemy is and Allah says
that very clearly in the Quran Allah
not bad bro but you know what's crazy
what's crazy bro is that like
we got two people you got the Believers
you got the disbelievers people who
believe and understand what a gin is or
even if they don't know what a gin is
but they believe in like something
that's unsung right right they'll
experience it they'll have experiences
and and they might feel something like
they might walk into a place they're
like yo like something feels off right
you know and then you have the
disbelievers who say nah this is not
real this is not real like there's no
such thing as a something that you know
there's no such thing as a ghost there's
no such thing as a Jinn it's like for
these people they're already in this
ignorant State they've like the Jin can
control them and do whatever they want
with them and it's like they for them
it's it's not a day don't make a
difference right see the Gin won't even
bother with them actually because
they're so extreme that's what they um
one of the interesting statements that
I've heard was that one of the greatest
tricks of of the devil is to convince
the world that he doesn't exist right
like people don't really think about it
kind of gone of course it's going to
Target the the Believers however there
are a lot of non-believers who
experience a Jinn and I was recently I
was looking at the
um the psychological manual for diseases
so yeah exactly so there's a column
there for unexplained uh psychological
phenomenon and a lot of the people who
have
these you know sometimes they'll put on
The psychosis and so on but there's a
lot of unexplained uh manifestations
which fall under mental health usually
but
the psychologists the scientists they
don't have where to put it so they put
under that category right and they try
to work with different medicine and
treatments however it's just like
possessions right they'll put it under
under there
did it come on random or was it
something that like came on no it came
out with time no doubt no yeah people
used to treat a psychologists evolved a
lot and people used to treat mental
health issues very differently uh they
used to inflict pain they used to you
know like hot water cold water
treatments uh like torture all kinds of
weird and interesting things and of
course things have changed over time but
now I think they kind of put
unexplained esoteric right right no 100
um subhanallah like that's that's one
thing that I find phenomenal bro so the
first thing I want to say you know how
you draw you drew a parallel between
bunny Adam and jyn right that we both
have free will I also think it's similar
to the Jinn and the angels have
something similar that they're both
unseen right at least unless they decide
to not be right but one thing I also
wanted to say was we did a whole series
with Mr middle path right for Gen series
editor you can put it up uh you know to
plug that for people that don't see that
but it's a series we did and we looked
at scientific studies on people that
take DMT like the drug DMV and they come
across these things like DMT entities
they call it we compared those with
people that claim to have alien
abductions we came across those that say
they were wizard Vibe vampire or ghost
all of these things have very similar
elements and we concluded that it makes
the most sense that they're gin because
they present the same things they give
them the same messages that slip into
kofor eventually and it's it's very
similar Bros Savannah and like it's a
whole world that people don't know about
and these drugs they do kind of lower
their hijab that we have with the Unseen
psychedelics right I mean that's kind of
what it does yeah to to remove that
hijab as you've said and get you past
that and just in the in the DSM too but
for anyone that doesn't know the DSM is
just a catalog of psychiatric disorders
right in the DSM they have this thing
called multiple personality disorder
yeah and what's crazy is I've seen
people that have multiple personalities
what I've seen patients that you know
when they switch from like one altar to
another and I've also seen Rokia videos
where they're doing multiple gym
possession
and there's too many things more similar
than different bro I'll just leave it at
that I mean look at this how can you
explain someone's never had exposure to
a language like Latin
a dead language yeah right that they can
speak all of a sudden you know just
flown 100 it's impossible you can say
okay like German or French you might
have in this in your you know in the you
picked it up and it's been recorded in
your subconscious and then they explain
it like that right but like a dead
language you know it's a solution
impossible and what's what's crazy is we
know that jyn can have their own Deen
right they can all have their own belief
system they could be Hindu they could be
Christian they can be Muslim and we know
that they could be any even a country
even atheists right the communities too
and what's weird is in multiple
personality disorder in the DSM
psychologists conclude that they your
Alters can have their own way of life
their own sexual identity their own
orientation their own religion and
there's so much like aligning bro with
gin that it's crazy
but have you have you dealt with any
cases bro in your career or yeah I mean
there's I've dealt with cases in my
career as a counselor when I was Muslim
but I've also experienced it as a
non-muslim
and I think
depends again what culture you're coming
from
like the
Eastern European the Latin called chirai
like Romania Spain
Italy Portugal of course South America
you know Mexico there's that it's it's
part of the culture the whole ghost and
spirits and Saints and Saints and
exactly right encounters with uh spirits
and so on like you're talking about
people in bulk and they consider it like
if you look like like Romania right like
the Catholics in Romeo specifically
um Catholics in like South America the
Italian Catholics you look at their
altars it's just doesn't even fit with
Christianity I mean it doesn't really
you know it's there's all kinds of uh
Saints and weird shirk that is not even
part of the theology but it's been
kind of uh injected into the culture
and people have have uh
you know Witchcraft and uh all kinds of
witches who are involved
um it's they learn it they pass it on
from from mother to daughter and so on
and so forth sadly I mean I mean again
it's like mostly women involved in this
kind of stuff you know it's kind of
weird but in most cultures like the the
Latin cultures it's usually women who
are involved like old women and then
they teach their daughters my grandma
was involved in that stuff
and I remember clearly
um that they used to do this um
they basically uh to to see if you have
like iron on you they'll use a match
and then they they do some kind of weird
ritual with a match with fire
and then they sub they allow it to drop
in a cup of water and then if it
submerged or something I can't remember
exactly then okay you have something and
then they make you drink that water
it's kind of weird but like everyone
does that you know
so there's that culture that is is is in
there so we've experienced a lot of
these these things
different places that are haunted
right uh
I mean that that's something that we've
come across as non-muslims I don't know
you probably like have uh have seen some
of that in your culture right like uh
you've even heard of something yeah see
we got we got Brothers on the podcast
who's a close friend of Sheikh Tim
humble and both of them have been making
Rokia videos and they talk about you
know the sahir of the magician they have
to do extremely humiliating things in
the eyes of Allah like extremely
humiliating and disrespectful things
either with fecal matter or menstrual
blood and all this stuff either eating
it or or sodomy with their brothers and
stuff like that wearing red and just
completely disobedient kofor stuff just
to get the approval of Jin just to make
that exchange and then finally gain the
trust but before I know what the viewers
are here bro they want to hear all the
Gin stories but I do have a question
that's genuine like there's this belief
in the Muslim Community I don't want to
claim it from Islam because Allah but
it's in the Muslim Community that we
shouldn't talk about Jinn stories and
it's not something we should be open
about like have you heard anything like
that because anytime you know people
have gin encounters it's like oh we're
not supposed to talk about it you know I
don't know I mean I feel that in our
community we talk about it too much we
blame jyn for everything
so
someone can't get married oh it's gin I
don't feel well oh I have iron oh
something you know my car broke down oh
it hasn't
yeah of course these could be it but I
think we've we over Overkill when it
comes to that it has to be a balance
right we have to check it out what's
um
mental health what's biological what's
psychological what's actually genuine
how do you do that through Specialists
we don't know I feel that
yeah we jump
too fast into labeling into gen and so
on so there's I mean there's extremes
you look I believe it's like
the more
technologically inclined we are
the more we dissociate ourselves from
believing in the Unseen in general it's
not that we don't believe theoretically
but we don't feel it it's like okay we
believe that there's Jen and Angels
whatever it's all cerebral you don't
feel that yes it's really there and back
in the days when technology was not so
so popular I think people are more
inclined not only to believe that these
things exist but to believe in God in
general oh 100 bro when you when you
look at like when you look at people in
Japanese tribes right following a
religion of no God atheism right and you
ask these kids that are living with the
way of the land they're they're Farmers
they're living in the mountains right
they all believe in one God and what's
what's profound is that one God the way
this they describe it to be omniscient
and Omni omnipowerful and omnipotent
right no omnipresent but all of these
things it aligns with Allah subhanallah
in the descriptions they use it's kind
of crazy but this being said do you have
any cases or any profound stories that
right that are for sure like you can't
just rule it off as mental health you
can't write it off as coincidence yeah
100 so I think so that's why I kind of
try to split into so pre-islam whatever
we experienced culturally you know
seeing our grandparents our culture
especially people in the village and so
on and then
what happened in Islam I remember the
first time I was it was during my first
a year and the in the UAE
and I was assigned a room in a hotel an
older Hotel
yeah and I I just you know I was like
what 25 or something and I I went you
know I just got a new job as a teacher
I was tired just reached the UF long
after a long flight got into this room I
went to sleep
and I wasn't sleeping yet I was just
tired I was kind of you know laying
around and all of a sudden like I felt
this
it was just got very cold
started shivering right I was like
what's going on you know like I couldn't
fall asleep I was like twisting turning
and
it was dark
and all of a sudden I felt the presence
this presence in my face
it was so weird because my eyes were
closed and I was like don't open your
eyes and literally like I know people
would be like yeah right it was like
like it made this noise you know and I
could feel the breath it's like you know
if I get closer you can feel it close
your eyes if I come close to you you'll
feel me you know there's someone there
why don't you do that once you get real
close
[Laughter]
so imagine yeah yeah and I was like
don't open your eyes well I got I was
petrified man on a lot of times
petrified you know it's crazy because uh
before we started recording I was like
you know I don't really have too many
stories or anything like that you just
reminded me of some things
before I moved I was I was laying in bed
um I don't remember what time it was or
anything but I was laying in bed and I
had this really weird moment where you
know how people like have these lucid
dreams of sleep paralysis where like
they're they're awake they can see but
they they're kind of sleep they can't
move when they see things I was asleep
but almost as if I can only see Darkness
so my eyes were closed but I felt like I
was looking and I'm just I'm lying down
and this I can feel my body lying in my
bed right and it's almost as if I can
see my body and my feet and I see this
thing kind of just walk or float just
around me it looked like a woman goes
like a shadowy figure come come around
me go to my feet at the edge of my bed
and it's it's like it either entered my
foot or left my foot or grabbed my foot
or something and then I just woke up and
I could not move at all I was aware I
was present but I couldn't move at all
first people say they're dreaming but
I'll review that in a second yeah you
want to tell something I was gonna say
that I had a story too don't forget your
thought though I know you have an
important point but basically there was
this one time and then anyone that's an
OG for t3m they've heard the story time
again but this one time I woke up right
like I had a good sleep I slept like a
baby and for some reason I felt inclined
to go on my camera roll to check my
photos I know like you have to be an
absolute crack to wake up and the first
thing you do is go on your phone
obviously is that alone is it I try not
to do that right but for some reason I
felt inclined have to go to my camera
roll and I think who does that waking up
right so I went and then I see a
recording from like 3 A.M or something
like that and it was recording in my
room
and I was like okay I slept at like
midnight and I know I didn't wake up
because no one wakes up and forgets and
I don't record stuff right and it's a
recording where basically under my bed
and my parents are gonna get scared now
because this was at their house I still
lived at home at the time but my mom
she keeps like our spare mattresses
under our bed and she puts like the
mattress padding you know and all that
plastic wrap so you could hear some it's
a black recording because it was night
obviously it was dark but you hear
something clawing at the mattress
padding and which is under my bed so you
can't even say like I I try to like
rationalize it right and try to like put
my hands as I'm sleep you can't touch it
bro it's like deep inside you know and
I'm just like bro like that makes no
sense right so I'm trying to like think
like what could it be and then I keep
listening to the audio and all you could
hear is it's like tearing away at the at
the plastic and automatically you hear
footsteps running away
um and it's just just something ran away
so next day I'm like kind of like in a
trance I'm like what could this be so I
called my dad I'm just like Dad did you
wake up like last night by any chance
he's like yes I was like were you in my
room like because I'm like what the heck
and he's like no
I was like what time did you wake up
he's like uh I wake up I woke up at two
different times I woke up once at this
time which was like much later it was
not that but then the time that the
recording was he was like I woke up
and I stayed in my bed just like looking
into a blank and I could just feel
something was weird and I was like what
did you do and he was like oh I just got
up and I just prayed Fajr
and I was like what time did you pray
Fajr like I need the time he prayed
father and he gave me a time he gave me
the exact time it was the exact time of
the recording
I don't know and and I don't know what
it is about Salah I don't know if they
don't like it or what but there was this
one time I was praying too and as soon
as I like I lifted the Tasha with finger
in front of me there was a couch and the
couch decompressed as if something was
sitting on it
which is insane and like no one thinks
like you can you can see a couch
compress if someone's sitting on it
right but the way the couch was I didn't
look at it because it was like it's a
normal couch but it came up in a way
which to its normal resting state and I
was just like bro that's weird bro and I
also had a this one guy who was a
magician he was basically telling me
um what I was wearing what I was doing
in my house who I was with and you can
obviously do that communicating with
someone's Kareen and all that and I put
two and two together later he was
definitely doing say her bro and so it's
like I don't know bro I've had my share
of experiences and I just want to let
anyone know that if you guys are
doubting these things to be real what
Gabriel's saying it's probably because
you either have low Iman and you don't
really fully believe in it or you
haven't had a direct experience with it
oh he's just been unaware or you're
unaware and I don't I don't wish this on
anyone obviously if you're unaware of
gin that's that's the paradise bro
that's Fool's Paradise but if you have
it it's it's not easy bro this is what I
think like the viewers should know that
the intention for this EP is a shed
light on this because a lot of people
they kind of go through life just
blissfully unaware of this but it's like
we're not saying it to scare you nor are
we saying it to like I don't know both
because like something that I learned
early on is like not to share these
things just because like let's be honest
you sharing that you sharing this you
sharing that I haven't said anything but
like y'all sharing this it's already
made us like feel some kind of way like
I don't know about each other but I felt
like like the Shivers in my body at some
point no doubt this like I mean I don't
know a lot Knows Best But
if you bring yourself to a lower State
and you also bring yourself to a state
where you can experience these things
even more and relax and I don't want to
make that on I don't want to put that on
anyone but that's why I'm saying like
this video yeah it's just to like shed
light on this oh you have to educate
people so they're aware yeah an example
of things exactly exist so they can
protect themselves yeah it's not just
for us to share Jin stories it's not
always not sitting around the fire and
just I mean bro go in bro if you have
any insane
but that's the uh what Allah says in the
Quran that shaytan he scares you right
and they feed on fear
right they feel in fear to us because by
intellect and fear they have stronger
physical abilities such as traveling at
the speed of light
going through walls entering people
stuff like that hearing thoughts some
Scholars have said
um definitely you know
identifying patterns in what you're
doing what you're what your weaknesses
what your strengths are things like that
I mean they're with you quite often so
they pick up on stuff
but the objective is to know how to
protect ourselves from these things and
that's what Allah keeps insisting
throughout the Quran to identify our
enemy
that's where the whole story of Adam and
Eve and shaytan is at the beginning of
the Quran in Surah
and that's what that tells us he
highlights this is your enemy
so take him as an enemy right he's the
one who made you fall
he's the one who got you to be where you
are this is his objective this is your
objective right and just the whole our
whole existence is somewhat tied to that
it's a test of life
is the the fruit the forbidden fruit The
Forbidden tree right not the fruit of
the tree
um and it's the weakness of the human
being that these Spirits explore
however that weakness and that plan
itself is weak right as Allah tells the
Quran
but it's us in the end through our
weakness that submit to them I'll go so
subhanallah I mean that was my first
experience and how do I get up but first
thing I automatic I was so scared I
started
automatically you know like like loud
like this I'm like I'm like you know
it's like in my face like that you know
like again it went you know the more I
was reciting the laurega and
I mean stuff realized bread didn't smell
or anything like that but it was like
cold and I can I could feel it you know
and it was like over me but not sitting
over like almost like hovering over me I
was it was freezing in the room you know
what I mean it was just freezing
and um
it disappeared I didn't finish at
turkosi
but I mean I finished it but back
towards the end it just it just
disappeared and it was tough to fall
back to sleep and I was just trying to
understand what happened the thing is
that's weird is that it kept coming back
almost every year
and the weird thing is that almost every
year it happened before Ramadan
um you had that too yeah it was like
absolutely similar almost to the point
that like you know uh like shawal comes
in uh
no shabans where it comes in and I'm
like already like whoa I gotta get ready
bro we'll lie yeah the same thing one
time again weird again in a hotel I'll
sleep in a hotel this was probably one
of the no there was another one that's
worse it came out of the pillow
and he tried to pull me in the pillow
almost like in a different
Dimension it was weird
it was so weird bro like that was such a
weird experience it literally grabbed me
from the pillow and tried to pull me
inside the pillow and again I was just
pushing without of course and just
resigning articles and let me go
and
the worst one was in Ramadan which is
weird because usually people think
that's it they lower their guard they
say Ramadan
but the prophet said the bad ones the
big ones are tied
the evil ones there's other ones who are
around maybe it's not that evil and it's
always the same one this one was weird
oh
I don't know
but I'm sure 100 I'm responsible for
what I say
and I was sleeping
I woke up went through Masjid pray Fajr
came back
and I was tired and I said okay let me
lay down for a little bit laying down
and I was like sitting Lily I didn't
fall asleep I was laying down
and I spot I saw something coming in the
room
you know and it moves so fast
and Bros like I don't know how he
grabbed me from the feet and from the
head and it bent me
like literally and a weird thing is that
I grabbed with my hand as I'm screaming
I was like ah like literally how old
were you
um
probably 30 okay well into Islam yeah
but I felt I grabbed its hair man like I
felt the hair it was weird because
ideally I mean theoretically you
probably wouldn't be able to yes but I I
felt I grabbed this hair
and pulled as I was residing and but I
screamed because it almost broke my back
and I felt the pain and my muscles like
for days bro it's like you know like I
was suffering from that pain the father
are gonna be like that's a back spasm
bro
I mean you can say whatever it is you
can say whatever it's okay it's not
because it didn't happen it was and I
recognized with saying one you know it's
a guy uh straight hair dark hair like I
you know it's the same person
and never talk to me never I don't know
like the same indicated but it's the
same one right and
um oh my gosh boy it was the worst
experience because it was so painful
actually like I suffered physically and
I was like I'm strong you know like I'm
big but it just like went like like uh
effortless like you're a doll yeah and I
thought he's gonna break me into like I
just reacted by reciting right away and
just somehow I grabbed
right and as I grabbed this hair I
pulled but I felt it's weird because my
mind wow soft hair
but it was like weird
like that was like like what the heck
you know like what what is he using like
what are you called what is it Head and
Shoulders
conditioner but it was so weird bro
because the pain stayed with me for days
you know so
yeah there was those experiences
um one time I was uh I was introducing
sheikhu Sylvester's in one of the
lectures and I was reciting some Quran
and I heard this like crazy scream in
the audience but I was like you know I
was like whoa I was like thank you
or something right because I was like
okay and then after everything happened
this lady came up to me non-muslim
she's like I gotta talk to you I was
like okay what do I do now you know I
was like and she's like yeah did you
hear that scream I was like yeah like
that was me I was like okay
and she's like I don't know I just when
I heard recite Quran I started screaming
like crazy
right and she's like I don't know what
to do blah blah but I had this like I'm
not gonna name the nationality again
because people get sensitive because I
have this boyfriend he's a Muslim and I
don't want to be with him anymore so he
said he's gonna do something to me like
he threatened me and uh how do I you
know like every time I hear Adan because
she's in a Muslim country and Quran this
is how I just start screaming like crazy
like I lose my mind I don't know what
happens
of course she's in a Haram relationship
why would you not be involved it's poor
woman it's all but I mean like you're
talking about a non-muslim you know so
all these experiences a Mecca like I was
praying I'm talking about praying in
Mecca and Haram and all of a sudden
someone like three rolls down going this
is so common in the horrible what did I
message you when I went to amra yeah
right at the Cabo in front of the Cabo
I'm praying and sisters are screaming
during Surah Allah and people do it okay
I've seen it there I've seen movies just
kind of circles there and some Sheikh
comes and just like does it so
um people need to understand there's a
balance
uh with how you look at this
but you have to to believe so you know
exactly how to protect yourself through
the rokua through the ascar you know the
recitations of the reminders and um I
mean it's become a fit now because I
know of some communities have split over
belief for example there's an Indian
Community
a southern Indian Community where
there's split huge spit for like 10
years now whether on this whole Akita
issue whether jyn can actually possess
you or not
and it's caused a huge division amongst
brothers and something look shaytan just
kind of you know that's one of his
objectives right to split the people
denying position I think well you're
talking about like organizations falling
apart like families dividing you know
can Jim possess so we will not he cannot
this is uh ridiculous not from some and
some people say no of course they can do
you have do you have any cases like you
know working as a counselor or a
psychologist working with people and
helping them out do you have any like
anything like you've heard from people
that they've told you things that are
you can't because I know you deal with
mental health and mental illness that
you you can't write this off as a mental
disorder no you cannot not when you have
so many examples they have specific
patterns patterns can you give some yeah
so um
as we just discussed right like these
like people knowing languages that they
wouldn't be able to know otherwise
um just you know Muslims and non-muslims
experiencing the same thing of course
people dismiss it and try to put it
somewhere on their mental health or
unexplained or will it will find it
later maybe in science is advancing and
so on
I mean it's just like recently I was
what we were talking about right one of
my clients was talking about how I guess
this um
thoughts to draw stuff you know and I
have actually I'll show you guys the
right I won't show it now but
um it's obviously confidential but
um
it's amazing what this voice is telling
her to draw like there's no way she's a
convert like how recently
um the the case yeah two three weeks ago
okay so she's a new River no she's been
a Mustafa for a few years okay and
um actually it's funny she left the slab
because of this
I'm trying to keep working with it but
there's no way this person can draw
these things impossible it's like Arabic
calligraphy words mixture of words
um the patterns it's just something that
is impossible you know what I mean for a
person if you were to say just like
whatever some gibberish or anything like
that you'd be like yeah it's just from a
product from the mind of a person what
is your wedding though
um just different words different uh
uh patterns different chronic kind of
you know it's not Quran but that's kind
of what we said that's kind of what you
find in tawi's when I've opened I always
before you'll find like names of gens
different words from the Quran gibberish
mixed patterns tables numbers and so on
so
when you see these things I mean I can
just there's too many cases to dismiss
them and to say that yeah it could be
just a coincidence it could be it's not
look in the end a person can believe
whatever they want
uh but when you experience it
is reality we don't want you to
experience it we pray that you never
experienced that that's our objective
teach you to be aware but if you do
experience it you should know what you
have to do and um when you it's not
about believing it it's about being
aware
right like knowing that it's there
because when you're aware of it if you
know what you're dealing with
it's not going to shock you as much
but when you don't know you have no
knowledge of it it could cause you to to
lose your mind yeah like people lose
their minds people become you know
um
they go on medicine
um everyone you know I mean they
themselves think because they cannot
explain they think that they're crazy
right so then they they come they act
crazy they take medicine they're on a
slippery slope they get admitted to a
mental
life is done right but if you would know
that could for the Muslims the Muslim oh
I know what this is right away the
mindset is different yeah you're not
going to panic you're not oh you might
be afraid but you're not going to panic
you know what you have to do and
sometimes bro I don't mean personally
my experience is strengthen my Iman
you know I became much stronger because
I was like like this is what Quran says
and this is what happens I'm like what
more do you want
um
I got a question though
just for all y'all because I don't think
neither of us is going to have the exact
answer but why do y'all think that there
are certain people that experience more
prone that are more prone and there are
others that are not I know I had said
the whole thing about this particular
unbelievable like in reality let's we
have a Believer so we we all have like
we have a group of Believers and you
might have like two people who like for
some reason they are having these
experiences left and right while the
other ones is like they know about it
but they don't really have these
experiences yeah okay so I wanna I wanna
come jump at it and you know
multifaceted approach so I think the
question that you're asking
is not alluding to a bunch of people
that are just unaware I think genik
encounters and experiences could happen
to everyone right everyone's open to
them but I do feel like a lot of these
people are just not conscious enough
they're not present enough to notice
these things something might happen in
the room something might happen in their
TV because tomorrow they do interfere
with electronics and stuff too no doubt
and people are just gonna be like oh
it's the power went out a lot of people
are just unaware or they might have
something to handle they're just on
their phone a gym could be just in the
room they're just they're just stupid
bro like they're not even Pleasant you
know there's no way to put it but I do
think
well the commonalities you're talking
about some people just have a history of
gin patterns in their life right or one
gin coming out for them the answer that
I'll give is Allah I have had a lot of
gin experience in my life and I try my
best to be a practicing brother I can't
say I'm a good Muslim because I don't
think any of us should slip into that
territory of saying we're good Muslims
or we're amazing or guaranteed gender or
anything we shouldn't say these things
stuff for Allah but I do see this a lot
that I know people that are not on Dean
like they're struggling with their Islam
and they have a lot of cases and I see
some like them that are not and I see
brothers that are really getting there
getting on D and they're on their p's
and q's they're not having cases at all
and then I see other brothers have them
what I do know is from all the brothers
that I've seen that I regularly you know
chat with and they have encounters is
the ones that were on Dean but they're
trying to get more on Dean just like
brother Gabriel was saying when they
were kind of in jahiliyah so to speak
doesn't need to do anything to you yeah
but as soon as they try to get their
life in order as soon as they try to
like get their Salon time step away from
Haram try to break up with their
girlfriends and these things bro shaytan
is at the door bro everywhere
I don't know um I was in my office I got
a call
sister Sri Lanka sister said look I need
to come with my sister she's got some
issues
uh she's got possession blah blah she
describe everything to me right so I'm
coming over
as I come by it's in Malaysia
so I just remember
so she comes in this little girl you
know you're talking about like I mean
she's a woman but she was like little
now I'm like
five foot Max you know her sister and
her cousin or whatever guy this guy
right so there's three people in front
of me so she's sitting next to me like
this and the guy and the girl all right
so she's telling me that's what happens
I get these you know
um it's like shaking and talking and
doing all kinds of weird stuff right
main point that we have to go on back to
your question is not that
each person experiences gin individually
is that sometimes a group of people see
the same thing happening now what how
are you gonna do you know can you say no
it's this person's psychosis or no itama
three four people saying the same thing
from different backgrounds different
understandings different even religious
commitment or whatever you can't deny
that bro
so I'm sitting and I was like look I was
like can I do some rock on you
it's like yeah yeah you know people have
tried and I'm like I wasn't ready for
that right I was kind of like let's just
do it see what happens so I recites were
back on her all of a sudden she's like
like this you know she's heavy actually
no I stopped reciting and we're just
talking and I kept mentioning some
things to use after reciting all of a
sudden her head was like I noticed I
thought are you okay I thought she's
tired
she's kind of like you know almost like
fall asleep you know sometimes you're
talking to somebody going on okay so
she's like dozing off right
and she put soon the third or fourth
time she lifted her head up her face was
different her eyes you could tell the
skin complexion okay check it out
she jumped on me
she choked me I've never like
even when I do Jiu Jitsu bro it's like
cannot compare okay her power
like I was and I was shocked I got
caught off guard right he started
choking me bro
like literally right and like trying to
get me in a lock
I was it took me three four seconds to
react yeah to break her guard and Lily I
took her to the floor bro I mean stuff
online but I took her to the floor and
like five foot girl did that to you bro
I had to wrap my from the back I had to
curl from the back right
and wrap my legs around her and choke
her like a proper choke oh I was like
I'm gonna kill her you know because bro
I couldn't control even then I couldn't
grab her bro just to grab my put my arm
around her bro it was impossible it's
just that I use my legs
so I'm tall obviously five versus six
two and I was able to wrap my legs
and the other ones were like they're
like just like they couldn't even do
anything like we've seen this before
it's not gonna go well and they're
sitting on the side and looking I mean
in panic they don't know what to do and
I'm trying to control her and I can't
bro I can't you know what I mean it took
me a while to grab her and I kept
reciting on her as I'm like choking the
thing out of her right I'm like that's
it she's gonna like just let it go right
and I'm reciting and reciting after
Coursey and finally I felt like you were
like
you know kind of thing and then she just
the whole power disappeared everything
just
went soft as a vegetable
and I talked to her I was like can you
hear me she's like yeah like can I let
you go or you gotta like say uh what
happened when she saw what she said what
happened that's when I let her go and
her face was different everything was
different
she's like I'm so sorry like you know
start apologizing crying she's like this
happens a lot you know I start hurting
people
bro it was that was just
unbelievable the power the strength that
this five foot little Sri Lankan woman
had
it was probably unexplainable bro I mean
I rolled with guys bro but this was
something different you know
I mean this was just
and one more thing too as men we always
size up people come into our room right
ready bro so when you there's a level of
your guard that you don't have when
you're just in a room full of women you
know what I mean I know I know I'm not
gonna really you guys can relate to that
you see a five foot short girl bro
there's no threat in the room whatsoever
so that's probably what flipped you out
more when she started to grab you and
choke you right if you're in a room full
of men okay I understand that you know
where I was like like
just a shock Factor alone would have
been like so much adrenaline you know
yeah what's crazy is that we actually
don't use
I think we don't even use like 15 15 I
might be saying this wrong um but we
don't use 100 capacity of like our
strength but if you have adrenaline
questions to your body like this is why
you hear like grandmas or like just
ladies or like kids or something being
able to do stuff where you're like yeah
yeah they wouldn't have missed a car
yeah now what's crazy if you think about
this if a gin takes control of your body
they can essentially control like the
capacity of like how much power output
it's amazing without right it's amazing
it's legit doing most of the work that's
what the Hadith said right because uh he
said that shaytan flows in the blood of
the son of Adam
it's like flowing really uh in this in
the blood stream of the son of man and
what's you know blood carries all the
hormones all you know see that's what
I've seen a lot of people that have chin
possessions they when they get possessed
their blood is really warm and they're
feeling flashes of heat you know and a
lot of them that are not possessed that
have gen near them they feel really cold
because the gym is fire right so it's
extremely warm so they feel Shivers and
yeah I haven't heard him talk I've heard
only one
recording of a brother who did a Roka
session they recorded
um I did hear obviously stories like
where people start talking to them where
that Jen even told them why they're
doing this and so on and so forth this
one's funny one the one that I listened
to the recording
because the guy made me listen because
it's funny
they were talking Tommy's like the brick
yeah they're talking to the gym and
doing rookia
he said I saw the prophet saws
he said like I'm from his time a lot of
them are old here yeah so he he learned
English but he spoke Arabic but the
funny thing is they're making they're
doing okay I'm fighting with the genus
like three people on the gym
and like one of the Imam says leave this
poor boy you know like you have no heart
like I'm like no don't you feel for her
he's like I'm a gin you idiot
I mean it's so funny
because I'm a genuine idiot
how dare you
oh but it's real bro it's legit yeah I
mean it's it's it's important
my advice to people would be like just
get informed study
um
okay if you want to read a good book
because obviously there's a lot of weird
stuff out there yeah about gin and so on
but uh
series and in that there's one about the
Jinn and the world of the Unseen
and uh it's a great book it's a shorter
book but it gives you the evidence from
the Quran sunnis to what our gen so on
and so forth
these stories from the time of the
prophet sallam he interacted with the
Jinn and so on and so forth how to
protect yourself and yeah like Basics I
mean
anything from the chronology
these are things that you can do to to
protect yourself
had a lot of you know is this he's
different than a lot of prophets in in
in context of Jinn can you give a little
bit of that for the viewers I mean that
was part of the um Dua that was answered
I lost my time for him to have a Mulk or
a Dominion Dominion yeah no one has ever
seen or has had so Allah has given him
that ability to control so they're
scared of him right because you could
punish them
now um so do you control animals or just
gym he can control animals he could
command them the the wind as well I
think his army was was huge the birds he
could uh speak their language and
understand and so on and people say like
oh how is that possible simple man
there's there's horse Whispers you know
today right I mean that's the closest
you would get but obviously because
people are just dismiss things as soon
as they hear something that to them it
doesn't make sense right away
again due to technology and the world
that we live in where no if I don't see
I don't believe in it dude there's a lot
of things you cannot see and you still
believe in yeah right
uh it's it's it's a it's irrational to
dismiss something just because you think
it's folk yeah or you think it's uh oh
it's not possible just because you don't
believe in it doesn't mean it doesn't
exist there's a separation between truth
and your personal belief
so there and you can draw a lot of
parallels from today's world in context
to prove that this is it can exist and
it is a possibility so with suleimanal
Islam Mia they're diving they're getting
purse for him you know and it's amazing
subhanallah that when he encounters
bilkis right and he decides to to invade
and why it's because they're worshiping
the Sun and
there's this power struggle where
finally she submits to him you know she
realized that his powers just cannot
um
the Jinn who goes to grab her throne
right one says look I'll just bring it
to you uh before he can stand up
right so which means you're talking
about so there's somewhere in like
Palestine that area
and this was in Yemen so we're talking
about my flight
um at least three four hours by flight
right but he said by the time you stand
up so you're talking about like what
second and a half maybe
so you can calculate actually there's
because you can see the distance between
beta not this and Yemen for example you
could calculate the speed and some
Scholars have done that but then then
Allah says in the Quran but then the one
who had knowledge of the book says I'll
bring it to you before you blink
right
can you imagine that before you blink if
you go like this and you'll and that's
exactly what happened that's exactly
what happened that's when you know it's
like you know it's like it's like
justice just a blink of an eye
so traveling no not just that traveling
that fast
teleporting or I don't know changing the
molecule structure of that
chair or that Throne to be able to carry
it and reassembling it I mean sometimes
you know like particle theory and you
can't make this up yeah it's you know I
mean if you put things together you
analyze but sometimes we read these
things but we don't think about the
details let's kind of go over it but if
you are to put it together you're like
wow you know then you watch all these
like Star Trek and people like yeah but
hey wait a second look at where we're
going with technology
right things are happening now so now
all of a sudden
these stories
are not stories anymore they're starting
to come alive like oh okay right I mean
just
just imagine like 50 years ago right
these cameras have a memory card
some of these memory cards are like what
100 GB 50 one terabyte bro one terabyte
or you can fit all of the libraries the
books in the libraries of the world
digitally on these so imagine 50 years
ago staying with a little card in front
of people let's say us 50. no don't
believe us and you'll be like hey I mean
you put it we'll put you in a mentor
they were crazy what do you mean the
books are all in this yeah because look
how big one book is yeah yeah but you
see the the way we think
yeah and the way
we deny is just because to us oh we
haven't experienced it that therefore
it's not true yeah that's the problem
when most people don't believe in God or
in the Unseen so I haven't experienced
it it's not true no it doesn't make
sense to me and they just dismiss it
so you can't you cannot you have to
think twice
think twice wait take a second
humble yourself I mean I think to to be
able to experience these things and to
know how to protect yourself you need to
humble yourself
first and foremost like any pursuit of
knowledge
then Allah will show you these things
and you'll know how to protect yourself
and your Iman will increase yeah
so before we start closing out because
we only got about nine minutes
I'll go to work huh yeah before you go
to work one question that I wanted to
bring up you know how you were saying
the whole thing about like some people
are aware some people are unaware
um the other thing that someone can go
from a state of awareness
to a state of unawareness
when it comes to Jinn
let's say they're going to they're like
experiencing experiencing experiencing
and then like they just stop
experiencing it
what do y'all think
um I think that can be experience and
then not experience yes can they go from
being aware to an away I don't think so
most people that are aware and have
direct experiences it's really hard to
like let go of these things and like
well that's what I'm saying if you look
at like there's some people they'll be
in the room and like let's say like the
light starts flicking or something yeah
and like we'll we'll say for the example
purpose that that's a gin that's a gin
like messing with it
this person will see that and like
they'll be a will and be like oh damn
like this is a gin like I have to do
something I have to like read
um Chrissy and you don't have to protect
myself here right but then let's say
they get to the point where they they
just I don't know something inside them
like they just don't want to experience
it anymore or they just they're no
longer focused on it they're focus on
other things because of this now it's
like when this happens they're not even
looking at it as like oh that's a gin
they're just completely like it's it's
not even there it's like there's a veil
now it could be possible
definitely yeah that's interesting why
not
I mean look at it even the story with
the girl I totally forgot it sometimes I
need to remind myself that these things
exist I think
going on with your daily life
your mobile phone your car everything
makes sense one plus one adds up to two
everything's just very linear you get
used to it sometimes yeah you slip you
just don't realize
that these things can exist I believe so
I think
we go into like a state of mindfulness
heedlessness like
you've experienced it
but you forget
and that's where insan in San
you know we forget and like where you
forget where you're coming from you know
your background your
people get rich they forget they're poor
at once people just forget those
experiences that they've had
because of what happens in their life
and they'll become unaware and they put
their guard down
the reason I asked man is because like
I've
I've had a lot of gym experiences and oh
man I knew when you asked that where you
were going but I just remember right now
one thing a lot I know bro
we got six minutes we got six minutes
but I'm not trying to like keep this
real short right so I have a lot of gen
experiences and it got to the point
where I'm I'm doing exactly what I'm
telling you it's almost as if there's
like a veil and I no longer really like
experience these things I no longer even
take notice of them but
and he's the big butt when I'm in that
like in between State when I'm like
about to fall asleep but still awake
that's when I'm reminded that like no
there is no Veil oh I have to take you
you're not you're not unaware like it
didn't disappear like it's all still
there and that's why I'm asking y'all
because it's it's weird man like my my
conscience day-to-day life it's as if
like I'm I'm no longer aware but then
when I'm in between it's like
let's talk about this when we all go out
for dinner tonight because I I can
relate to that this is some unfolded
stuff I would say we'll put on patreon
guys but we're banned from patreon so
what do we do guys there's no unfiltered
place but you can say your thought real
quick
um but I I do relate to that and Gabriel
had a thing like right before sleep too
okay um there's members in my family I
don't want to name any names you're
watching you know who you are that have
that too it's because when you're right
before you fall asleep it's it's such a
like your hijab is down bro it's no
inhibition bro but what was the thing
you okay so this brother I mean he's a
new Muslim he's a Thai brother
yeah like I've heard this from him he's
a convert how he converted to Islam so
he went to Thailand his his mother's
ties his father's uh another I don't
want to say it because I don't want
people to something private but he told
me the story and
so
he went to Thailand he was trying to get
spiritual
and basically uh he went to the temple
and he gave him a little Idol that he
has to take care of with that Idol came
a gym
the spirit and he had an instructional
like he was seeking certain
Enlightenment and certain things so the
monks there gave him that but so you got
to do like this like he has to feed them
he has to do certain acts of worship
towards him and so on and it was a baby
or a very young not a baby but a young
gin
he almost like had to take care of it
for years this relationship was
developing they're living together they
were doing things for each other
and whatnot
the Gin entered into contact with
uh with Muslim Jinn
and he he became Muslim yes and gave Dao
to the guy
and the guy became Muslim I mean the
story is long I could say another it's
an amazing story but just because we
don't have time
when I was and he's telling me the story
and he's a new Muslim
and
he became Muslim he gave doubt to his
brother his brother became his very good
friend by his brother both that we do
projects together we work together so
his brother became Muslim as well
so the Jinn gave Dao to the guy who's
taking care of the gin
and the brother gives out to the other
brother they both becomes
however this is a cool apartment
subhanallah he said
they went to Juma one time
it was one of the first jumas like they
went to one of the Muslim areas in
Thailand or something like that they
went to Juma and there the Jin met some
other genes so after Juma I said the guy
said I didn't see him anymore
finally came to me says we can't be
together anymore because these guys told
me were not allowed because you're not
allowed to communicate in Islam it's not
permissible
so he said uh
like I'm a proper Muslim now and his
name was Nu
Nu so they said they named
all right so they name it Noor because I
just wanted to say salaam for the last
time and you know it was great being
with you and alhamdulillah guided both
of us
but it's the last time I can talk with
the jinn's name was new his name was but
the other gens in the messenger name
[Music]
insane
but it's I mean the story is longer yeah
we don't even have a website to plug
right now
guys if you made it this far smash the
like button if you don't know who
brother Gabriel Armani is what are you
doing links in the description go over
to this channel subscribe like his video
show him some love inshallah send this
to someone in your family send this to
your mama your grandmother anyone that
doesn't believe in Jin or might need a
little bit of a boost to know that
they're not the only one going through
this inshallah
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]